am I going to consider this this woman
as like a serious something a bit more
serious like more serious partner then
I'd be thinking well hang on a minute
this is a bit of a red flag no uh I'm
not really you know I'm probably not
into that now you we can talk about this
open yeah so she sure they were in a
relationship I guess you and your
boyfriend just recently broke up because
of this guy friend seriously yeah yeah
were you [__] the guy no it wasn't
had sex with any of my guy friends but
like when when you get to know
when you get to know me I walk around
with a dick I really genuinely like in
my head I genuinely think I have a dick
so I'm one of the boys okay when you get
to know me you'll see because even he
says it I'm one of the boys so I have a
lot of male friends not very many female
friends because my female friends can't
handle a joke okay like a lot of females
cannot handle a joke and I joke too much
so when I'm around guys they're you know
they tend to be like I wouldn't [__] you
so what happened would that cause a
relationships
they wouldn't [__] I disagree with that
too you guys can disagree I actually
like I can call him right now and be
like hey
have you ever have you ever done it
before no ask them to have sex no no but
don't hold on for a year they will hold
on for years
you have to talk to him in a way that he
thinks it's
but that's the thing it's hard to do on
a phone call right like you're gonna
call him hey do you want to have sex
with me they're like what are you doing
you know I was thinking something yeah
for so long like why haven't we dated
I've always liked you no we've never
liked each other no no that's who you
should say to him but don't you have an
emotional connection me and your friend
okay so me and my friend I call on my
brother he calls me his sister that's
literally the dynamic I introduced him
to dabrick as my brother and he believed
it until I told him it wasn't well
this is my sister
but
even still you can tell when someone's
not their brother you can tell you're
just like it's a little flirty and Troy
what do you have to say so it's a little
flirty so it's a little flirty you just
but you just said it's a little flirty
as I didn't say that about my
relationship
so me and my brother are not flirting is
is it possible that he's a little bit
into you I'm curious what did you think
did he want to [__] well I just met him
his brother I was like hey whatever like
I mean it took her word for granted but
the point is is that you had a phone
call with him right and he called and
your boyfriend so this was another guy
because I have multiple male friends
that's that's the issue is gonna want
that no guy is gonna want it the
disagreement isn't this the disagreement
was I said she's and again I'm not
attacking Lana I was saying for me it's
a respect issue it's not an insecurity
but I also know how men are yeah right
and I have a choice she has a choice we
have a choice but when I met when I met
my gal she put herself in a position to
say you know what she didn't have she
goes she moved but she's like I don't
these are guys I grew up from high
school she cut communication so I don't
want to disrespect you and I let her
hang herself and she's gonna hang
herself but I don't have the insecure
but I know guys I'm a guy and we all
said I simped before I used to be that
guy back in the day I hung out with the
pretty girls Dennis Rod Dennis Rodman's
ex-wife the basketball player was a
friend of mine we kind of hung out his
friends I simped I hung out with the
opportunity and then as I got my game
and my frame and my muscles and my money
and I figured the game out I was like no
I'm not doing that and we can just hang
on well first of all not I'm not
referring to Lana why do I want to hang
out with you I'm busy hustling making
money I'm dating somebody we can be
friends there's no value unless I'm
having sex with you I don't want to hang
out with you as a woman and so for me
Pearl's a friend from a distance we've
went to dinner with my girl with pearl I
will never disrespect girl but at the
same time I'm not gonna go hey Pearl
let's go hang out let's go play
basketball
she's a woman I'm a man I got tested I
wake up with a hard on it's like I said
hey what are you doing come over watch
Netflix and chill I know what's going to
happen yeah I never asked that she asked
me she asked me the other night she was
here I'm at the hotel I'm in my Linda
right now I'm just kidding
and she goes she goes here's my Linda
Ray
it
'd be so but not to disrespect Lana but
for me I have a different standard and
so it wasn't the guy as much as you're
sharing intimate conversations with this
guy and we're on a trip and he's calling
you hey hey buddy how's it going oh I'm
here we're having a good time it just
feels like I'm dating three people
totally
yeah okay yeah Evan we're just like
talkers like we just like say sometimes
we're done and we don't see the
difference it took me a long time to
learn the difference and I'm like you
know it took me 30 years to learn that
yeah it did yeah but the thing is like a
lot of times we share private
information about our relationship and I
just think when you're sharing that I do
that yeah and so it's like it's kind of
disrespectful and I'll turn I'll turn my
guys like my guy friends against my
boyfriend yeah
okay I'm like no I have a question like
would you ever like change that if you
felt like it was getting the way of you
of you getting a partner or boyfriend
long time to become okay to be
completely Fair it's the reasoning
behind that is because my my guy friends
have done a lot more for me than a guy
about the boyfriend has had has done oh
do you want me to put the show no
I I understand like where you're coming
from because you know I'm a tomboy so I
like that that's always but it's like I
just think in a relationship it's not
appropriate like I just don't think you
can like I don't think we grew up
watching our moms and the wives really
have a bunch of guy friends hanging
around doing favors for them but yeah
and like there's one day you just wake
up and realize everyone's trying to [__]
you and I'm I'm really confused how you
haven't had that like realization yet oh
I have that's the thing oh so you know
they would your guy friends not my guy
friends that's the thing that's what
that's where you're trying to turn the
you're trying to turn the story into
that it's not that that is with other
people but when it comes to but you've
had some guy friends for for a long time
and you know those dudes those dudes guy
friends
I have had guy friends in the past that
have tried to [__] me yes yes no but
these friends that hang up these friends
that I have the friends that I have
right now have never tried to [__] me
and these are friends like one of them
has been friends with me no no they
haven't they won't okay and I know that
for sure but either way but now you
broke it up with your boyfriend has
anyone said oh yeah I didn't break up
with my boyfriend over that no but
whatever regardless Oh Come Around you
know I'll come for you you know
like these are these are people came my
boyfriend doesn't pay my bills my
boyfriend doesn't live with me there's
problem number one
wait it is not my boyfriend's
responsibility to pay my bills it is not
his responsibility but if you live did
you live together no oh okay okay so you
don't live together okay that's not
really yeah we were together for two
months oh oh that's totally that's what
I'm saying
it wasn't a mind you I was with this
person for two months yeah I've had my
friends for 10 years my friends were
there for me when I was homeless my
friends were there for me when I got
raped my friends were there for me when
I was getting divorced yeah it was I was
friends with them while I was married so
these are people that are don't play
with that too much
yeah I mean I can sort of I can sort of
see by sides on this because I I know
for sure I mean so here's the thing
right as a guy I don't really I don't
really have female friends I've got a
lot of women that I know that I'm kind
of friendly with you know we'll have a
bit of banter blah blah blah I'm not
really I mean I was a little bit in
Miami actually because I haven't seen or
I hang out with this girl pixie and
stuff but even them they're kind of
people that are sort of it's almost work
related in a way you know they're kind
of people that I know through these
shows and all that [__] but I'm not like
there's no women in my life at all that
I'm just friends with like oh hey guys
should we go and hang out and hang out
on Saturday but that's just me that's
that's my that's the way that I operate
you know my friends are guy friends but
at the same time there are certainly
women that I know that I have zero
sexual interest in and we're kind of
friendly and I know it's never gonna I'm
never gonna slowly turn around and go I
really want to [__] her do you know what
I mean it's just not going to happen so
I do accept that you know that there are
these there can be these sort of male
male female friendships but as a guy
when you're going into a relationship
with a woman I would see it I would have
some I would have concern about it
if you don't know it and also just just
even if you're not gonna [__] them
there's something about the level of
intimacy that you might have with those
dudes which is security well which might
make him think security
it's him it's his protecting his husband
yeah almost anyone's Investments or
maybe you should invest in me first damn
yeah that's what I was trying to get at
like that's why I was saying yes I
understand he he doesn't need to pay all
your bills but he needs to show that
he's showing enough of an interest in
you that he is number one and you're
gonna make him number one and yeah and
that's obvious and then he'll become
secure with whatever else is is in line
like make him number one and and listen
to him wait what are you gonna say hold
on hold on what are we gonna say oh I
wasn't I thought you said before he had
to pay for everything but you kind of
walked back on it so no I don't I don't
no I don't necessarily well she don't
even with a dude yeah she's not yeah and
you're not living together it's a
different type of diet totally different
type of dynamic I thought it was like a
marriage what were you gonna say you're
going to say something I was actually
gonna ask uh Troy a question so do you
like so I understand that because I
agree I mean I was like Pearl and like
Moana like I I always grew up a tomboy I
played Sports I did a lot of things I
was like one of the guys I grew up on a
ranch and I rode dirt bikes yeah so I
was around a bunch of dudes that my dad
trained every weekend ready yeah so I
had a lot of guy friends because girls
didn't really like me and then we don't
I didn't like the drama of women yeah
that's typical for what women say it is
true it's just true it is because women
are catty and for some reason women are
always in competition with each other
which is stupid but when I so I had more
guy friends but like when I started
dating my husband like I that just kind
of fell off and then like I stopped
talking to like my guy friends because
I'm like I don't that's not appropriate
anymore but I understand because he
proved that to me he's like it could be
your best friend and he could be gay but
he would still want to [__] you or at
least see you naked and the problem is
like you want to move the exact same as
a single woman as you do as a wife and
we want to give up nothing for the man
oh yeah and I give up if you didn't like
I give up everything and I have no
problem with it so but do you think that
a guy because I've had men argue with me
saying that it's it's not the same for
men because when we see women and we
don't we're not sexually attracted to
them but that doesn't mean that the
woman doesn't have her own intentions so
do you think that it should be equal in
that aspect like if you genuinely want
to be with this person that you should
phase off your stinger girlfriends yeah
well you mean female if anything yeah
like female friendships you should fight
yourself
um
with yourself like is there am I chasing
this friendship because there's a one
percent chance that I'm still looking
for something or do I really not give a
[__] more genuinely friends that's
and that's rare
there's no sexual desire like no I have
no sexual desire for this person we're
just really close like like there she's
like my sister but at the same time that
doesn't mean that you don't know if she
secretly has feelings for you for the
opportunity
for a woman that's where intuition is so
this is where our society teaches us so
tuition sucks like drug dealers women's
intuition is the dumbest well that's
where our society
if our intuition was so good you'd be
married like
I said that I got divorcedure it's just
so good that she's picked a loaded guys
you had intuition that they cheated